[Music]
Hank Azaria is in the exciting new show
Brock Meyer rock Meyer the premise being
sponsored us all talk like this yeah I'm
giving you some do I do
yeah I do a deeper version you do how I
sent the show the Bob Kahn I'm gonna
tell you as Jim brakmar good I said to
show off to many baseball guys I thought
might get a kick out of it one being
Costas and Costas most loved it he
called it the generic baseball announcer
voice which is how I think of it as long
as you give the count you can say
whatever the [ __ ] you want and Phil
Rizzuto did this a lot with the he would
most talked about the Italian meal he
had the night before like oh man I had
some sausage and peppers at the at the
valio it was wonderful as Johnson swings
and misses of a breaking ball all in one
and what are you talking about these
guys say I you gotta forgive me ladies
and gentlemen
I had a bit of a rough night last night
but with local law enforcement about an
eight ball of coke and a Filipino hooker
named the waywe johnson swings and
misses at a breaking ball oh and - I
mean hey just say whatever he plays a
sports with us but not a sports
announcer like this who is here I'm not
sure if he's like I think maybe I'm
being a DJ up here yeah a lot of guys on
radio back in the day morning Drivetime
one of our guys ability high high houses